do you
ever stop and think during a romantic
dinner
i've just left my fingerprints all over
my wineglass
or do you ever worry when you visit a
friend about leaving a little piece of
you behind
on every surface that you touch and even
this evening
have you paid any attention to sit
without touching anything
well you're not alone thankfully
criminals
underestimate the power of fingerprints
too
and i'm not just talking about the
twisted pattern of lines that
make our fingerprint unique i'm talking
about
an entire world of information
hiding in a small often invisible thing
in fact fingerprints are made up of
molecules that belong to three classes
sweat molecules that we all produce in
very different amounts
molecules that we introduce some in our
body and then we sweat out
and molecules that we may contaminate
our fingertips with
when we come across substances like
blood paint
grace but also invisible substances and
molecules
are the storytellers of who we are
and what we've been up to we just need
to have
the right technology to make them talk
so let me take you on a journey of
unthinkable
capabilities
katie has been raped
and their lifeless body has been found
in this woods
three days later after her disappearance
the police is targeting three suspects
having narrowed down their searches
from over 20 men in their area
on the same day the only piece of
evidence
is two very faint overlapping
fingerprints
on the tape that was found wrapped
around katy's neck
often faint and overlapping fingerprints
cannot help the police to make an
identification
and until recently this might have been
the end of the road but this is where we
can make a difference
the tape is sent to our labs where we
asked to use our cutting edge technology
to help with the investigation
and here we use an existing form of mass
spectrometry imaging technology
that we have further developed and
adapted specifically
for the molecular and imaging analysis
of fingerprints
in essence we fire a uv laser at the
print
and we cause the desorption of the
molecules from the print
ready to be captured by the mass
spectrometer
mass spectrometry measures the weight of
the molecules or as we say
the mass and those numbers that you see
there
that indicate that mass but more
crucially
they indicate who those molecules
are whether i'm saying paracetamol
or something more sinister forensically
speaking
we apply this technology to the evidence
that we have and we found
presence of condom lubricants
in fact we've developed protocols that
enable us to even
suggest what brand of condom might have
been used
so we passed this information to the
police who meanwhile
had obtained a search warrant and they
found
the same brand of condom in dalton's
premises and with dalton and thompson
having also records for sexual assaults
then it is chapman that may become the
less
likely suspect but is this information
enough to make an arrest
of course not and we are asked to delve
deeper with our investigation
so we found out also the presence of
other two very interesting molecules
one is an antidepressant and one is a
very special molecule
it only forms in your body if you drink
alcohol and consume cocaine at the same
time
and alcohol is known to potentiate the
effect of cocaine
so here we're now having hints on the
state
of mind of the individual whilst
perpetrating the crime
we passed this information to the police
and they found out that actually thomson
is a drug addict
and he also has a medical record for
psychotic episodes
for which presumably the antidepressant
was prescribed
so now thomson becomes the more likely
suspect
but the reality still don't know
where these molecules are coming from
from which fingerprint
and who those two fingerprints belong to
fear not mass spectrometry imaging can
help us
further in fact the technology is so
powerful that we can see where these
molecules are
on a fingerprint like you see in this
video
every single of those peaks correspond
to a mass
every mass to a molecule and we can
interrogate the software
by selecting each of those molecules as
to
where they are present on a finger mark
and some images are not very revealing
some are better some are really good
and we can create multiple images
of the same mark in theory hundreds of
images of the same fingerprints
for as many are the molecules that we
have detected
so step one for
overlapping fingerprints chances are
especially if they come from different
individuals
that the molecular composition is not
identical
so let's ask the software to visualize
those
unique molecules just present
in one finger mark and in another one
by doing so that's how we can separate
the two rich pattern and this is really
important
because the police now are able to
identify one of the two fingerprints
which actually corresponds to katy
and they've been able to say so because
they've compared the two separate images
with one taken posthumously from kt
so now we can concentrate on one
fingerprint only that of the killers
so then step two where are these three
molecules that i've seen
well let's interrogate the software show
me where they are
and by doing this only portions
of the image of the killer's fingerprint
show up in other words those substances
are only found are only present
in the killer sprint so now our
molecular findings
start matching very nicely the police
intelligence about
thomson should that fingerprint belong
to him
but the reality is that that print is
still not good enough to make an
identification
step three why don't we since we can
generate
hundreds of imaging of images of the
same fingerprint
why don't we superimpose them and by
doing
so trying to improve the reach pattern
continuity and clarity
that's the result striking
we now have a very clear image of the
fingerprint
and the police can run you through the
database the match
comes out to thompson thompson is our
killer
katie the suspects and the circumstances
of the crime are real
but the story contains elements
of the real police case work we've been
confronted with
and is a composite of the intelligence
that we can provide that
have been able to provide the police
and i'm really really thrilled that
after nine years of intense research
as of 2017 we are able to contribute
police investigation mine is no longer a
dream
it's a goal we're gonna do this
wider and wider bigger and bigger and
we're gonna know
more about the suspect and we're gonna
build an identity
we i believe this is also a new era for
criminal profiling
the work of the criminologist draws on
the expert
recognition of behavioral patterns that
have been observed before
to belong to a certain type to a certain
profile
as opposed to this expert but subjective
evaluation
we're trying to do the same thing but
from the molecular makeup of the
fingerprint
and the two can work together i did say
the molecules are storytellers
so information on your health your
action
your lifestyle your routines they're all
there accessible in a fingerprint
a molecules are the storytellers
of our secrets in just a touch
thank you
you